biggest change which was the
introduction of a big Child Care Subsidy
um
you should have a link to slido to ask
questions so please do that we will
leave plenty of time for questions at
the end and do vote up questions that
you like I will see those
first
we are aiming to finish dead on 12
o'clock so we shouldn't detain you for
more than an hour and a half of which
hopefully no more than half will be us
speaking and the other half will be you
asking questions and us trying to answer
them uh the um
you can't see them but a few of my other
colleagues are also lurking on this call
and hopefully between us we'll be up to
answer most of the questions that you
put
um but let me start by just making some
introductory uh comments I think the
first thing to say is a course that Mr
Hunt was presented with a slightly
better fiscal Outlook than he faced in
November but don't forget it's still
much worse than we expected a year ago
it's very much too easy to compare these
numbers with the most recent ones
actually looking back even a little way
in history is quite important Mr Hunt
decided to spend the larger part of the
windfall that he's got since November
but know the difference with what
happened in November then the forecast
got much worse he just lived with the
extra borrowing
so if they get better and you borrow
when you use the extra borrowing they
get worse and you keep the extra
borrowing that's how borrowing ratchet
is ratchet up uh year on year
the two big ticket items were a child
care offer for the under threes and a
temporary full expensive for expensing
for investments in corporation tax there
was more money for defense than the
traditional and this time particularly
expensive cut in the real terms level of
fuel Duty
as far as the economic forecasts are
concerned the obr are much more positive
than the bank of England and the many
other forecasters about medium-term
growth the chance they should be
grateful at least for that small Mercy
but to repeat what I said back in
November it is slightly odd I don't know
if it's damaging but it's certainly
slightly odd that we have our monetary
policy and our fiscal policy made on the
basis of two extremely different
economic forecasts
despite uh those uh relatively somewhat
uh better
um economic forecasts uh over at least
the short run the outlook for the public
finances does still look difficult
tax continues to rise to its highest
ever level and to much higher levels
than in recent decades yet even with
very tight spending penciled in from
2024 debt is barely falling and that's
because a high debt level high debt
interest payments additions to debt not
included in borrowing and sluggish
nominal growth make it hard to get debt
on a decisively downward path this
really matters to quote the obr it is
now harder for this Chancellor to
deliver a falling path for the debt to
GDP ratio in the medium term than it has
been for any of his predecessors since
the obr was established in 2010 that's
quite a statement not least remembering
where we were back in 2010
as a result Mr Hunt was hemmed in by his
own fiscal Target to get debt falling in
the last year of the forecast period
while it's level the level of debt that
is is expected to be lower than November
the trajectory remains stubbornly flat
and that has led him to rely on a
combination of tight spending plans
imaginary future increases in fuel
duties and a fiscal gain from
unwillingly undoing its corporation tax
change at the end of the period in order
to appear to meet this rule this is not
a terribly sensible way of being Guided
by such rules
Matt said this budget did lay out some
elements of a sensible strategy to
support growth there's plenty to quibble
with and I will quibble but if you want
to focus on growth there's at least some
of what you might want here attempting
to deal with incentives to work and to
invest now much of the focus was on
getting more people back to work the OVR
awarded the chancellor by suggesting he
might have some success in this but the
numbers are modest if the total effect
of the measures is indeed to get just
over a hundred thousand more people into
work as the obr suggests and let's
because that is a very uncertain
forecast that would be just a fraction
of the number lost from the workforce in
the last couple of years alone it's
dwarf by annual net immigration numbers
assumed that 245 000 even the change in
assumptions about migration increases
the numbers in work by 160 000. over the
period the obr reckon the overall labor
Supply package will cost about 7 billion
a year an increase in employment by
around 120 10 000 that's a cost of
nearly seventy thousand per job
obviously the money will do other things
like provide child care but it given the
Chancellor's focus on increasing the
numbers of jobs I think that's an
interesting calculation to make
now if this budget is remembered for
anything and I do think it should be
remembered for this I think it will
actually be one of the few budgets that
will be remembered in 10 years time and
it'll be remembered for the extension of
free child care to working families with
children under the age of three
this is a major expansion of the welfare
state it's sort of the end of a journey
at the start of the century very little
preschool child care was paid for by
government at all we'll soon be spending
over 8 billion a year with the
government paying for over 80 percent of
all formal child care for preschoolers
in England now that that brings risks
for the child care Market if provision
is not funded appropriately my colleague
Christine farkelson will talk us through
that but it also reflects a major change
in the scope of the welfare state and
our expectations of what it should
provide it's an example actually of a
ratcheting up both of expectations and
the spending
the impact with this this will have on
labor Supply is highly uncertain though
the obr score is the biggest policy
contribution to increasing numbers in
work the main effect will actually just
be to reduce the cost of child care for
those working parents who would have
paid for child care anyway that's not
necessarily a bad thing but it's
important to acknowledge
while there are also welcome reforms to
ease life for Universal Credit claimants
making use of child care this is
actually the logical endpoint of a
journey which started Remember by
focusing on Early Education and reducing
inequalities at the start of school but
has ended with an overwhelming focus on
providing child care to Working Families
to reduce their costs and allow more
parents to work those are completely
different objectives so there's been a
big shift from spending on poor children
to a universal offer for those with
working parents or near Universal
one policy that really won't play a big
part if any increasing the number of
people in work is the increase in the
pension tax annual and lifetime
allowance
even on the obr's it might be optimistic
assumptions this will come in a hundred
thousand pounds a job there's a case for
allowing people to save more on a
pension even if those who gain will
generally be on high incomes
but what while it was sensible to
accompany this change with a limit on
the size of the tax-free lump sum to 25
of the existing lifetime allowance it
was to say the least disappointing that
other over generous aspects of pension
taxation not least the complete freedom
from inheritance tax were not rained in
at all
the lack of any coherent strategy here
remains deeply disappointing don't
forget these changes are largely a
rowing back on changes made just a few
years ago by this same conservative
government
somewhere else where over recent years
there's been in my view a complete lack
of apparent long-term strategy is
corporation tax not only have we had the
main rate taken all the way down to 19
and then all the way back up to 25 we've
had ever changing policy in most other
aspects
moving the full expensing of plant and
Machinery investment as proposed
yesterday does make some sense
but first if this was the direction of
travel it should have been announced
when the higher rate of Corporation
taxes announced what possible excuses
there for making change of this scale
and this and it is a big change fully
two years after that announcement
leaving companies ignorant of what was
to come next second formally doing it
temporarily whilst claiming an ambition
to make it permanent only adds to the
uncertainty in the system this appears
to be done largely to help meet the debt
rule this really is the tale of a badly
designed fiscal rule wagging the dog of
fiscal policy government needs to learn
that stability and consistent long-term
strategy are vital for companies looking
to invest and therefore for securing
better living standards and third and
importantly this change will only apply
to investment in certain assets and will
actually end up providing a big subsidy
for debt financed investment
that is not a good thing there is much
more about the corporate tax system
which needs sorting out my colleague
Isaac de Lester will say rather more
about that so very disappointing uh that
no more done there no sense of strategy
and that it's been done on an apparently
temporary basis
the other substantive policy aimed at
increasing numbers in work is the plan
to end the so-called work capability
assessment for disabled recipients of
Universal Credit
instead the health assessment currently
used for a totally different benefit
personal Independence payment available
to help with the extra costs of living
associated with disability irrespective
of income or work status will now serve
a dual purpose
by also determining whether those on
Universal Credit can get additional
means tested support
this is a potentially radical policy but
it's also a risky one the idea is that
capability for work is not a simple
binary and those with health conditions
that only partially limit their capacity
to work should get support without
facing such distance strong
disincentives to find a job
but the Dilemma is the following about a
million people on Universal Credit are
deemed to have work limiting health
conditions but are not currently
receiving personal Independence payment
under these proposals then 600 000 of
them could end up losing 350 pounds a
month and 60 of those have mental health
problems
to avoid that the government could widen
eligibility criteria for personal
Independence payment but remember
personal Independence payment is also
available irrespective of income or work
status so far so to far more than those
now on universal credits so the
potential for yet another upwards
pressure on disability benefit spending
would be considerable after all is the
non-means tested disability benefit
co-slave caseloads have been on rapid
and long-term upward trajectory even
more benefit spending decisions are now
to be loaded onto that part of the
system in some very careful design is
needed to avoid either runaway spending
or hitting low-income sick benefit
recipients or potentially both there's a
long way to go in getting the design of
this policy right my colleague Tom
Waters will say more about that
what about the rest well uh just to
return that was the inevitable and
fiscal sleight of hand that pretense and
it just is a pretense that fuel duties
will always rise next year when they
never rise this year it's becoming
increasingly weirdism it makes frankly a
bit of a nonsense of the fiscal forecast
if you can't even undo a supposedly
temporary five per liter cut to duty
when the price of the pump has fallen by
something like 40p you might as well
admit defeat there was no discussion of
public spending Chancellor left his
post-2025 spending plans
unchanged in cash terms
ever so slightly higher inflation in the
obr forecast reduce the real terms
growth rate associated with those from
one percent a year to 0.9 not a big
change some additional spending on child
care and defense takes the growth rate
back up to one percent so in that sense
nothing has changed since the Autumn
we're back where we started but within
that we're now going to spend more on
child care and defense so Less on
everything else the spending plans
outside of charcoal and defense are even
tighter than those announced in November
what about what he really didn't say
nothing on public sector pay now in my
view it is simply impossible implausible
that there will not be extra money
available you cannot keep cutting the
pay of teachers nurses and civil
servants both in real terms and relative
to the private sector without recruit
consequences for recruitment retention
Service delivery morale and as we've
seen yesterday and today strikes money
will have to be found from somewhere
perhaps the chancellor will dip into his
fairly substantial 14 billion reserve
for next year to fund the one-off or
backdated pay award more generally the
argument this is not affordable
astounders on the fact that Mr Hunt
found 20 billion a year yesterday for
other things this is of course as all of
this is a question of choices and
priorities finally what households are
going to feel over the next year will be
continuing pain inflation may be coming
down but prices remain much higher than
two years ago earnings haven't caught up
the freezing of income tax on Nick's
personal allowances and thresholds will
cost most basic rate taxpayers about 500
pounds next year and most higher rate
taxpayers a thousand pounds
the OVR may be relatively optimistic
about the medium term but it still
thinks these will be the worst two years
on record for household incomes its
projections suggest that real household
disposable incomes will be no higher in
2027 than they were in 2019 barely
higher than in 2017 and a lost decade
one might say another lost decade for
living standards the obr's optimism on
the economy may not be widely shared for
a little while yet
I'm going to stop there that is my take
on some of the big themes of the
yesterday's budget you will now hear
much more detail and lots of pretty
charts from my colleagues Carl Isaac Tom
and Christine I'm going to hand over to
them they will go through their
presentations as they're doing so please
put your questions on the slido and then
we will come back at the end of their
presentations and answer your questions
thank you Paul so I'm going to start by
going through the obr's forecast for the
economy and for the public finances and
highlight some of the risks around those
forecasts
so let's start with the outlook for the
economy so the gray area here shows you
the range of independent forecasters
that are surveyed by the treasury each
month this shows you the the range that
was given in February with the solid
line showing the average of that range
so you can see there's a lot of
uncertainty there's not a lot of
agreement over what the economy might do
over the next few years
if we go back to November and look at
the obr's forecast that they had then
you can see they were actually
forecasting a much deeper downturn this
year but then a relatively strong
recovery or more optimistic about the
medium term than what the latest
independent forecasters are
if we look at the bank of England their
most recent forecast from February again
they're more optimistic about 2023 they
don't think the downturn would be as bad
as what the obr thought in November but
it's very striking over the following
two years they have a really dismal
forecast for uh growth in the economy
must really hope that that proves to be
too pessimistic
what the ABR presented to yesterday was
a much more optimistic set of forecasts
they agree that we're going to avoid
that sharp downturn this year and then
we're going to return to pretty strong
growth and you can see that while
they're forecasters within the range of
independent forecasters it is towards
the top end and if you look at 2025 in
particular you can see that Mr Hunt must
really be hoping that the obr is right
and that the bank of England is wrong
about what's going to happen to the
economy certainly the public finances
and indeed our incomes would all be in a
much worse state if the bank of
England's pessimism turns out to be
justified
so the OVR more optimistic about growth
than they were in November more
optimistic about growth than many that
doesn't make them particularly
optimistic about what's going to happen
to household incomes over the next few
years
so the chart here takes the OBS forecast
for average real disposable income of
households and shows you how recent
history compares to those projections as
Paul just said essentially what this is
showing is that even by 2027
um incomes are around the same ballpark
as what they were in 2019 and indeed not
that different from 2017 or 2015.
um so a very poor period for household
income growth
um if we compare that to an alternative
world where post 2008 the economy just
continued growing household incomes just
continued growing at the rate we've been
used to we would now be much much
financially better off would be in a
situation where households incomes on
average for something like ten thousand
pounds a year bigger
so that shows you the level of household
income I think what the chart doesn't
really show you that clearly is how big
the decline is over this year and next
so let's just focus on that for a moment
so this chart's going to show you the
the average the change in incomes
between one year and the next each year
um that we have comparable data and you
can see there the obr is forecasting
that this year will be the biggest drop
in average household incomes and next
year the second biggest drop on record
so a very poor period for household
incomes despite the obr being more
optimistic than it was in November
Now One driver of that why a household
income is looking so poor given the
economy is not looking quite as bad as
we might have thought is what's
happening to taxes the government is
essentially taking a bigger share of
national income in tax revenues that
naturally will bear down on household
incomes
so the chart here shows you total tax
receipts as a share of national income
going back to 1948 and the latest obr
projections and you can see a pretty
steep increase in the tax burden going
on at the moment that's because of some
tax measures that Isaac will talk you
through later on and it's bringing that
tax burden up to levels that the UK
hasn't seen in recent decades by quite a
considerable margin and indeed up to a
level that the UK has never sustained um
in its history
so we're moving to a higher tax economy
what's this meaning for government
borrowing
well if we go back 12 months uh Rishi
sunak was Chancellor this is what he was
forecasting for the deficit uh four
percent of GDP this year declining to
just over one percent of national income
in the medium term
if we skip forward several chancellors
into the next uh set of obr forecasts
that we got that's November you can see
the Outlook had changed pretty
dramatically
um in particular two things have gone on
Russia had invaded Ukraine European gas
prices were much higher the government
had responded with a big package of
support for households and businesses
plus we've seen some other policy
measures that persist into the medium
term in particular the government had
decided to scrap the Health and Social
care Levy before it came in so a
combination of those things meant that
we're on calls to borrow more in each
and every year by quite a considerable
margin
how did the obr's forecast change
um well had Mr Hunt yesterday stood up
and said he wasn't going to do any
measures he was just going to stand up
tell us the forecast and then sit down
again we'd be on this path here this is
the pre-measures forecast the opr
presented the government so lower
borrowing not just this year and next
but lower borrowing throughout the
forecast Horizon as they believe that we
don't just benefit from less government
spending on the energy price guarantee
we're also getting more receipts that
will persist into the medium term we've
also got that extra growth which is
helping too
but as you'll hear from my colleagues Mr
Hunt did set out a set of measures in
particular some spending increases and
some tax cuts which mean that we're on
calls to borrow more than what that
pre-measures forecast would imply and
indeed over the next couple of years it
brings borrowing back up towards the
levels that he was forecasting in
November
so if we take 24.25 between March and
November the obr said to Mr Hunt well
actually we think that our underlying
forecast has worsened by 45 billion
pounds how did he react to that well he
essentially decided to borrow it all he
said well I'll just respond by
offsetting just three billion pound of
that extra borrowing through higher
taxes or lower spending the rest of it
uncomfortable to borrow now obviously
there is a case for doing that
but yesterday essentially the obr had
told Mr Hunt well between November and
March we now think in that same year
there's an 18 billion pound Improvement
so previously we told you things have
got 45 billion pounds worse now we think
things have got 80 million pounds better
how did he respond to that well he chose
not to bank any of that money he
essentially chose to give it all away
through tax cuts and spending increases
so in the first period things got worse
he decided to essentially allow
borrowing to rise in the second period
things got a bit better and he decided
not to allow borrowing to be lower
instead to give the money back and
that's kind of Ratchet effect when you
get hit by shocks will cause if you keep
doing it boring to be continually
increased over time
so Byron cut back to where he was
expecting in November over the next
couple of years it's worth noting at the
end of the forecast Horizon
um he didn't give away all of the uh
Improvement in the Outlook in terms of
lower through lower taxes or higher
spending he did choose to have a lower
profile for borrowing than what was
expected in November that brings us back
to a current budget surplus where the
government is only borrowing to invest
it also brings us back to what what's
known as a primary Surplus where the
government is actually only boring to
cover its debt interest costs
um that's pretty rare in the UK um so in
some sense the boring figures for the
end of the forecast Horizon do look
um an historical perspective arguably
reasonably prudent what does that mean
for government debt
so this is public sector net debt as a
share of GDP as forecast in November and
this is public sector net debt has
forecast yesterday
um you might look at those two lines and
if I was to ask you well which one would
you prefer to be the case if you're all
else equal which would you write which
where would you rather we were at I
think most people would probably pick
the blue line if all else could
genuinely be equal we'd presumably
rather have lower debt than higher debt
but Mr Hunt has a fiscal Target that
doesn't
um Target the level of debt it targets
the change in debt in particular it
focuses on the change at the end of the
forecast Horizon
back in November that was forecast to
reform very slightly um between Years
Years four and five Falling by a margin
of nine billion pounds on yesterday's
forecast it's actually forecast to Fall
by an even smaller margin a margin of
just six billion pounds um these margins
are absolutely tiny relative to the
uncertainty in projecting the change in
debt on that time scale
um to give you a sense of how tiny it is
uh supposing the obr revised down its
growth forecast its nominal growth
forecast by 0.2 percentage points that
would put you on course to miss the
target how big is a 0.2 percentage Point
revision well it's half the revision
that we've seen between November and
March
alternatively suppose Mr Hunt actually
said I'm going to freeze few duties um
throughout this period and I'm going to
boost public sector pay by an additional
one percent relative to what I'm
currently planning that would also put
you on course to see debt rising in that
final year so a very very tiny margin of
error debt could easily rise in 27 28.
so that naturally asks us a question
well Mike the chancellor have more
wiggle room in future what about when we
get to November we get to an Autumn
budget
um the date of the next general election
gets closer Mighty have some wiggle room
well at that point it's not the fall in
debt between 26 27 and 27 8 28 that
matters will roll forward a year it'll
be the fall in debt over the subsequent
12-month period um that will matter
and if we care about the true health of
the public finances um it's very
difficult to forecast what's going to
happen to dead over that period but I
think it's fair to say that many of the
pressures we see at the moment
um weak nominal growth the interest
rates the government's bearing the cost
of servicing the government's debt also
some things that add to debt which don't
count in borrowing they're likely to
persist for some time yet so I think in
a genuine sense it's not likely to be
the case that debt is going to be very
easy to get falling between 27 28 and 28
29. now what adding another year to the
forecast Horizon might do to the
chancellor is lead him into the
temptation of saying well I get an extra
year where I can pencil in perhaps some
tax Rises that I perhaps won't even do
maybe I'll pencil in another year of
increasing field Duty and line of
inflation or maybe our pencil in yet
another year of squeezing public
spending so that kind of thing will give
you some apparent Headroom
um but if nesso's policies really can be
followed through on it's not really
genuinely there and that kind of School
sleight of hand is exactly the kind of
thing we don't want to see in the Autumn
budget
so how easy is getting debt down over
the medium term likely to be well
notwithstanding concerns about how
difficult it is to forecast this I just
want to show you a couple of very very
broad brush illustrative scenarios I'm
going to ignore those things that add to
debt that don't count in borrowing I'm
going to assume the government runs a
primary balance so it borrows only to
pay for its debt interest costs over the
longer term and I'm going to assume the
interest rates remain where they're
currently expected to be and what the
graph shows you is mathematically what
would happen to debt as a share of GDP
under two scenarios what if growth
follows the eobr's expectation of
long-run growth or what if it follows
the bank of England's expectation
if we're in the iovr scenario you can
see that debt is falling as a share of
GDP over the medium term you might argue
whether that's decisive or not it would
still see debt at 80 of GDP in 2040.
under the bank of England forecast I
think it's pretty clear that there isn't
really a decisive fall in debt and the
next time a bad shot comes along for
example the recession is pretty clear
which you debt ratcheting up again so
that would really not be a great
physical situation to be in
supposing growth was in line with the
bank of England forecast and there was
nothing we could do about that and we
wanted to get back to that lower line
how much of a fiscal tightening would we
need to do well you'd be talking about
one percent of GDP so a tax Rises and
spending cuts totaling about 25 billion
a year in today's terms would be
required to get you from that upper line
to that lower line just as an
illustration
so one thing that's really causing the
difficulty here is debt interest
spending we have elevated debtors I've
just shown you interest rates on that
debt means we're spending more on debt
interest now the average since 2010 has
been that we would devote about two
percent of national income to debt
interest prior to the pandemic the
forecast implied it would remain below
that level and even if we roll back 12
months the forecast produced then
expected just a one-year spike in debt
interest payments before it falling back
down below that two percent level
that's no longer the case the November
forecast and indeed yesterday's forecast
suggests that while death interest
spending is spiking this year it's going
to return down to a level that's well
above that two percent average and we'll
be spending about one percent of GDP a
year more on debt interest than what we
would have expected just a year ago that
makes all of the fiscal arithmetic more
more difficult for the chancellor
so I just want to finish with a couple
of key risks to the forecast one is on
public sector pay lots of pressure to
increase public sector pay not least
because many public sector workers have
experienced real pay cuts over the last
decade
looking to the next financial year
departments are claiming they can afford
within their budgets about an increase
of about three and a half percent
that would be lagging behind what the
obr and what the bank of England thinks
is going to happen to private sector pay
if the government wants to match private
sector pay growth you would probably
need to find something like two and a
half to five billion pounds to do that
if we wanted to go further and wanted to
try and unwind the drop in public sector
pay in the current Financial year
relative to private sector pay it would
need to find an additional nine billion
pounds to do that
now Consolidated public sector power
Awards might be difficult they're going
to be permanent they're going to add to
spending pressures uh on an ongoing
basis if we wanted to fund some back
dated Awards or some one-off awards the
government could look to its Reserve as
Paul mentioned it's got about 14 billion
pounds squirreled away in that Reserve
now the government might be hoping that
that's there for things like extra
support for Ukraine or extra support for
energy bills where Energy prices to to
move up again but at least some of that
perhaps could be devoted to public
sector pay Awards
the second pressure on the spending
plans really come from the period Beyond
April 2025 where I think the spending
plans look really
um quite tight particularly given the
chance they're now saying he wants to
get defense spending up to two and a
half percent of national income I'm just
going to talk you through an illustrated
scenario on that
total public spending is being planned
to grow by about one percent a year over
that period you might think well that's
not too bad you could increase budgets
all by one percent a year
but let's suppose the NHS actually sees
budget increases in line with its long
run average that's about 3.8 percent a
year
let's suppose given that the school
numbers are falling let's suppose the
government manages to freeze School
spending
but the Jeremy Hunt is serious about his
defense Target he wants to get to two
and a half percent of GDP at the end of
this decade and he wants to do that in a
straight line way well that means the
defense budget would need 6.8 a year
increases
overseas aid spending would need to grow
by 2.1 percent a year to keep in life
keep it 0.5 percent of national income
and if we're going to match if we're
going to pay for those Child Care
promises set out yesterday that's going
to require spending increases of about
12.2 percent a year
what would that mean for everything else
well it would mean cuts of about 18
billion pounds 3.2 percent a year on
average that's pretty deep cuts to areas
like local government further education
courts prisons and the like
and the final risk I want to flag is on
the revenue side it's about fuel Duty uh
so the line here shows you the supposed
plan for the rate of fuel Duty as set
out in June 2010 this shows you the
successive plan as every year that
whoever was Chancellor said I'll just
freeze it for one more year and then
I'll return to indexation and indeed
that's what the current plan implies it
suggested in a year's time we'll get rid
of the temporary 5p cut and we'll return
to RPI indexation
the obr has pointed out that over this
tote in cumulative terms over this
period we've given away about 80 billion
pounds in field Duty cuts and remarkably
in the coming Financial year field Duty
revenues in cash terms will be about the
same as they were in 2009.
if going forwards we want to continue
freezing revenues it will reduce
government revenues by about four
billion pounds in 2027-28
so to conclude over the next couple of
years the chancellor chose to give away
rather than Bank most of the Improvement
in borrowing that the obr handled and
handed him
over the longer term despite a return to
current budget surplus he's left with a
wafer thin margin of error against his
poorly designed debt Target and this
poorly designed Target might well be
pushing Mr Hunt into some unwelcome
policy decisions
there's lots of pressure to tax less and
lots of pressure to spend more and this
could easily lead to debt actually
rising in that year freezing field
duties retaining full expensing that
Isaac's going to talk you through and
avoiding departmental spending cuts
could easily cost the government an
extra 25 billion pounds wiping out the
wiggle room that the chancellor has
so I'll now hand over to Isaac who's
going to talk you through the tax
changes in a bit more detail
yeah thank you very much Carl so I'm
going to talk a little bit about uh
changes to the tax tax system now
um now uh the biggest change that we can
expect to see in the tax system uh from
April at least for personal taxation
actually isn't something the chancellor
announced yesterday it's something we
already knew was going to happen which
is that income tax and National
Insurance thresholds are frozen in cash
terms and from this year to the next
um uh now with inflation running at 10
this year that's really going to buy
pretty hard so what I'm showing you with
this line here is the additional uh tax
that someone at a given level of
earnings can expect to pay between this
year and next year as a result of these
threshold freezes you can see that uh
for basic great taxpays at least most
basic rate taxpayers they can expect to
see an increase in tax of about 500
pounds for those higher rate taxpayers
that's about a thousand pounds
um that's going to see about 1.7 million
people
um brought into the income tax system by
these uh threshold freezes and it's
going to see about 1.2 million people
um
paying higher rates than they otherwise
I would have done as a result of these
freezes now worth noting that's just the
impact from this year to next year this
is only one year of a six year freeze if
we look at the impact
um uh between now and the end of that uh
multi-year freeze uh I can show you that
impact on the yellow line you can see
it's going to be even bigger by the end
of this period most basic grade
taxpayers are going to be paying around
800 pound or more 800 pounds more a year
in tax most higher ed taxpayers that's
going to be around 1700 pounds a year
now in terms of things that the
chancellor did announce yesterday one of
the biggest changes to uh personal tax
uh was his
changes to pension allowances now there
are two major uh allowances in the
pension tax system at the moment there's
the lifetime allowance uh that limits
how much you're allowed to build up uh
in a pension over the course of your
lifetime and then there's also the
annual allowance which limits how much
you're allowed to push in a pension in a
given uh year now both of those
allowances have been cut but really
quite substantially over the course of
the last 10 years or so
um what did the chancellor do yesterday
well he abolished the lifetime allowance
entirely and he increased the generosity
of the annual allowance from its current
level of 40 000 pounds uh up to sixty
thousand pounds
um now that's uh clustered as being
about 1.3 billion pounds a year although
we'll expect it to be
um quite a bit less uh in the longer
term because uh a lot of the a lot of
the additional money put into pensions
is going to end up being taxed when it's
withdrawn from those pensions later uh
on
now
um why is the chancellor made this
change well uh a big reason is that
people have tended to worry that uh
particularly older workers bumping up
against these allowances uh might end up
uh withdrawing uh from the workforce as
uh as a result so the chances hoping
this is going to increase our labor
force participation increase employment
um now that could go uh either way so on
the one hand you could see that being
able to save more in a tax advantage
pension uh might mean that work is
rewarded more
um and if you can put more uh and
therefore might increase employment and
on the other hand it might be the case
that people are looking to save enough
for their retirement the ability to save
more in a tax advantage pension uh might
mean they don't need to work quite as
much to reach that goal so they might
even end up retiring earlier now the obr
thinks the first of these two effects is
going to be the bigger effects and that
overall Workforce participation
employment will increase
by around 15 000 as Paul said that's not
a really big number and it remains to be
seen whether uh that even ends up
transpiring
um in terms of who'll actually benefit
from this policy it's going to be those
who have the ability to build up a very
large pension pots in excess of the
current lifetime allowance or those
um who are well off enough to be able to
contribute more than 40 000 pounds uh in
a single uh year to their pension and
although it's worth noting that the
ambulance is still being reduced or
those with the very highest incomes also
worth noting that's still a pretty
stupid policy
um
now giving people the freedom to save
more in their pension if they want to is
a good thing whether they're rich or
whether they're poor
um what's not a good thing uh is giving
people who already have a lot of pension
wealth additional Tax Services to say
even more in their pensions now the
chancellor did take the very sensible
step
um of limiting the tax-free 25 to the
current level of the lifetime allowance
that does limit some of the subsidy that
gets provided to those with very large
pension pots through uh uh through this
reform
um but it's worth noting that isn't the
only subsidy to pension saving we have
in our current system there's also a big
National Insurance subsidy and also the
fact that pension pots are entirely
exempt from inheritance tax
um so those are additional subsidies
that are going to be handed out people
making very large savings uh under these
uh reforms so there are things to like
about this reform but what they do do is
that they really emphasize some of the
flaws in the current uh system
particularly this fact that uh we're
very bizarrely treat pension pots more
favorably there's inheritance Vehicles
than we do as vehicles for providing you
with an income over the course of your
retirement
now the other major tax change we saw in
the budget was to corporation tax now
what's been happening with corporation
tax
um is we've seen um a long-term uh uh a
long-term pattern of rate cutting
over the years now that's due to end in
April when we're going to have the first
increase in corporation tax in more than
50 years the rate's going to go up from
19 to 25 percent
now we can also look at the revenue from
corporation tax now this is revenue is a
percentage of GDP
um and if we look at the obl's latest
forecast we can see that um revenue from
corporation tax is due to reach its
highest ever level by the end of the
forecast period
what does that mean internationally well
it means that the UK's corporation tax
rate is going from being uh really quite
competitive one of the lowest in the
developed world to closer to the middle
of the pack although uh worth of
noticing it's still lower than that of
any other G7 country now uh there may
well be concerns that this could dampen
uh investment in the UK business
investment in the UK and so what's the
chance to have done about that well uh
in yesterday's budget the chancellor
announced um a temporary increase to the
generosity of the UK's tax allowances or
investment in plants and Machinery
um now that's going to take the UK's
plant Machinery investment allowances
from being some of the least generous in
the developed world to being some of the
most generous in the developed World
um at least for the three years this
policy is going to be in place worth
noting it is a temporary policy even
though the chancellor has indicated that
he has an ambition uh to make it
permanent
um worth noting this is only something
that's really going to affect the very
largest companies because all companies
are allowed to deduct the first million
pounds of investment plant and Machinery
um anyway and so this only going to
really affect those companies really
making very large uh Investments now
it's worth noting this is a really big
changing direction for UK policy over
the last 50 years or so we've seen
successive chancellors pursuing a
strategy of cutting the corporation tax
rate and and broadening the corporation
tax base this is basically the exact
opposite what we're doing now is
narrowing the corporation tax base and
increasing the rate
so how can we think about uh the rates
and allowances in corporation tax
together well one way we can do that is
by looking at the effective rate of
corporation tax that's
um the proportion of uh returns of an
investment that are taken in tax and we
can look at that effective rate for an
investment that only just breaks even
and the higher these effective rates are
the more the current system is
disincentivizing investment and now the
first thing to notice
um is that these effective rates vary
quite a lot depending on what a
particular company is investing in
different assets end up with different
effective tax rates uh on a uh on a
break-even investment that's not the
only way in which they vary they also
vary by how Investments are financed so
because debt interest is deductible
um for the purposes of corporation tax
debt Finance Investments are actually
treated much more generously in the UK
system and actually that often leads to
negative effective tax rates on those
break-even Investments which actually
means we're subsidizing investment it
means that we're allowing Investments to
go ahead that would be too low yield too
unproductive in the absence of the tax
system that's not a desirable thing it's
not a feature we'd like to have in our
tax system so how is this picture going
to change under the Chancellor's new
reforms
um well it's going to change like this
so the first thing to notice here is
that all investments in plant and
Machinery
um that are that are not financed by
debt and the reform is going to see
these uh zero uh uh effective tax rates
on those break-even Investments meaning
all tax will be collected on more
profitable Investments
um that's a desirable feature it means
that any investment would be worthwhile
in the absence of tax is still going to
be worthwhile under this policy so
that's a nice feature and something we'd
like to see in fact we'd like to see
zeros across the board and that isn't
something that's achieved by this policy
for a couple of reasons firstly it only
applies to plant and machinery that
means other kinds of Investments are
going to see their effective tax rates
unchanged
um there's also a big problem here with
debt Finance investments in plant and
Machinery where what the chancellor is
doing is actually increasing the subsidy
that we're providing to those
Investments and that means we're going
to be doing even more subsidizing of
those low yield potentially quite
unproductive Investments and that's
really not a desirable aspect of the
system
so there are trade-offs for this policy
there are certainly desirable aspects to
it but there are also ways in which it's
exacerbating elements the current system
that were already undesirable
now if this policy were put in place
permanently I think we would say that
it's a step in the right direction but
it really is hard to defend the fact
that it's only being put in place for
three years on a temporary basis why is
it only being put in place for three
years hard to think of any good reason
other than the fact that Chancellor
wants to make it look like is not going
to be spending quite as much in the
fourth year of the forecast
um particularly silly reason to do
things given that actually most of the
peak cost of this policies end up is
going to end up being recouped in later
years because all you're really doing is
moving forward in time
um the point at which uh these
allowances can be claimed and also if I
make it temporary we're going to end up
distorting the timing of Investments
firm's going to end up moving forward in
their estimates in order to land them
within this three-year window and it's
just going to add more instability and
more uncertainty uh to a tax landscape
which actually has just changed far far
too much in recent years and if you want
an illustration of that this is uh the
annual investment allowance and the
various planned uh trajectories of being
an invest in the lands that we've seen
in recent budgets uh from different uh
chancellors over this period
the green line is the actual path that
it followed and what this Unholy mass of
spaghetti shows is the government's
really pursued a policy that's been
extremely Mercurial changing its plans
um all
this on a yearly basis that's really not
what you want if you're looking to try
and build a tax environment that's going
to encourage businesses to make uh
long-term investment decisions in an
efficient way so just a few conclusions
to end with um so firstly it's worth
noting that these income tax and
National Insurance freezes really are
going to bind very hard next year as a
result of the high inflation this year
um in terms of the other two uh big
policies uh that the chancellor
announced yesterday on tax well the
first thing to say is that neither of
them is going to be quite as big as it
may look on the scorecard because a lot
of the revenue is actually going to end
up being recouped in the future for both
policies
um and the second thing to say is that
while both have aspects that are
desirable both of them
um can do do you have uh do you have a
positive aspect
um they also both exacerbate some of the
pretty undesirable features that we have
lately in our current system so still
plenty of room there to improve things
through reform
so that's all for me I think I'm going
to now hand over to my colleague Tom
who's going to talk to you a little bit
about the benefit system
great thanks
um thanks Isaac so uh unlike what the
two presentations you've just seen I'm
just going to talk about one policy
which we found out at yesterday and I'm
trying to very quickly and that policy
is the reform to health related benefits
So currently in the UK we have two
health related benefits with personal
Independence payments or pip which are
entitled to if you have disability
related living costs and it's not uh
dependent upon whether or not you can
work or your income and with the health
element of Universal Credit which you're
entitled to if you have a limited
capability for work and you have a low
income there are also some other bits
but it's not really totally clear what
the government's going to do with them
I'm going to ignore that in this
presentation
so the government's plan is to remove
any link between benefit eligibility and
the ability to work
and instead they're going to make the
health part of Universal Credit
dependent upon getting it
and now that adds up to a potentially
pretty radical reform it's a shift from
supporting people who have high living
costs or can't work to only supporting
the other and there are a few potential
rationales for having a high benefit
related to inability to work first it
replaces lost earnings I suppose that
can't work and secondly then this
relates to something I'll come back to
it reflects the fact that compared to
other out of work claimants those with
disabilities might be less responsive to
financial incentives
okay so that's the plan what um might it
do who's it going to affect so 2.6
million people get you see with a health
condition
1.6 million of them already get hit and
so will be unaffected by the reform or
indeed can even gain from it but another
million are not getting paid and so
potentially lose they might be required
to search for work and about 600 000 of
them could be in line for a 350 pound a
month loss in income though in the short
run all of them will be protected by a
transitional protection
now no doubt many will try to apply for
Pep to keep their current entitlement
but if their condition doesn't create
Higher Living costs many won't be
eligible and so will be tempting for the
government to try to widen the
eligibility criteria in order to protect
that one million and indeed they've
already made noises in that direction
the white paper yesterday they said for
this group we will carefully consider
whether they meet the pep eligibility
criteria and we will consider how
disabled people who need additional
financial support may receive it and
indeed they've already carved out an
exception for people with a pregnancy
risk or some cancer patients but the key
Insight here is that pip is not just for
low-income people and so any widening of
the eligibility criteria to protect this
one million group opens the door to more
claims from people with higher incomes
or less severe conditions
now of course there's many other people
who are not currently on any form of
health related benefit here I'm putting
on all those who are on any form of unit
Universal Credit you can see here
there's a 0.2 million group who are on
UC don't get the health element of UC
but do get pet they will pretty
mechanically gain about 350 pounds a
month but then there's also millions of
people who report having a disability
but aren't on any disability benefits so
if the government does decide to loosen
the eligibility criteria to pip again to
try and protect that one million group
there's potentially a large number of
people who might be looking to put in a
pip application
and this matters because what this plan
amounts to is to shift the system
towards the pit assessment criteria
rather than the UC Health capability to
work criteria but as you can see here
it's the pitbit that's been growing over
time
and so we're loading more of the health
assessment in benefits onto the part of
the system that more and more people
have been successfully applying for and
in addition any widening of the
eligibility criteria and the increasing
Financial reward for getting it might
put further upward pressure on that part
of the budget
so what should we um what might we think
about this reform so it strengthens work
incentives that was the government's
kind of key rationale and as you can get
into work or stay and work and keep the
health element that said a large
proportion of the affected group have
already been assessed by the government
as being far from work and so you might
see quite limited effects here
and secondly there will be fewer
assessments under this reform because
you only need to be assessed once rather
than twice for two separate benefits
that creates less hassle for claimants
and it also reduces cost for the
government
but there's there's risks and trade-offs
on the other side too first the one
million people on UC with health
conditions but not on pit will
potentially lose out from this reform
most of them uh financially here the
government faces a core trade-off they
can accept many low-income losers or
they can widen the PIP criteria and get
more High income less severely disabled
payments so there's a risk as Paul was
saying of runaway spending on the one
hand or having lots of sick low-income
people losing out on the other
second at the moment those getting UC
for health reasons have few job search
requirements applied to them but after
this reform there won't be any
assessment of work capability and it
seems that the plan is for work coaches
at Job centers to decide how much you're
required to search for work taking into
account your health conditions this may
be tricky for work coaches who aren't
health professionals and their decisions
are important because if job search
requirements aren't met payments will
get sanctioned
and third many more people will want to
apply for Pep because of this change
that might push up wait times for the
benefit which are currently at 14 weeks
but very recently have been as high as
26 weeks and so here getting the
resourcing rights in particular shifting
resource from the work related
assessments to the PIP assessments will
be critical to ensure that we don't see
learning wait times
that's everything I have on that policy
I'm going to pass over to Christine now
to Talk About Childcare
thank you very much Tom the final thing
that we wanted to talk about today is
the really quite massive change that we
saw in support for child care in the
early years in the Chancellor's budget
yesterday the biggest piece there and
the most eye-catching was the extension
of the free entitlement to funded Child
Care hours all the way down to children
from nine months to two years old in
Working Families the chancellor made
other reforms as well including changes
in the Universal Credit system and how
that supports families with child care
costs as well as some shifts in the
ratios that child care providers can use
and some incentives to recruit more into
the sector some of which I'll talk
through in this presentation
let's start with that free entitlement
funding because this is really the
biggest game in town at the moment we
spend about 4 billion pounds a year on
the existing free entitlements 15 hours
a week for all three and four-year-olds
15 hours a week for some two-year-olds
in disadvantaged families and 30 hours a
week for three and four-year-olds in
Working Families
on current plans spending was set to
fall slightly in real terms over the
forecast Horizon
that the chancellor announced yesterday
to existing entitlement funding will
more or less be enough to keep that at a
freeze at that four billion pound level
in Real terms
much bigger story though was the
expansion of the free entitlement a
30-hour offer all the way down to
children nine months to two years
that'll directly benefit around half of
families with a young child and it will
it's set to double our total spending on
the free entitlement going from about 4
billion pounds a year to about 8 billion
pounds a year this is a huge increase in
the amount of spending that we put into
the earliest years and as Paul said in
his opening remarks it represents the
fine one of the final steps towards
really incorporating those first few
years of life as something that the
government considers to be a core part
of the welfare state
most of the reform is going to be
subsidizing parents who are already
spending and already using formal child
care for their young children we
estimate that around 300
000 30 hour places will be paid for by
this reform so even before parents
change any of their behavior they're
currently paying for this child's care
and now they'll be getting that from the
exchequer so this is a direct transfer
from the public purse to parents
the government also expects uh
reasonably significant labor Supply
impacts from this reform the obr thinks
that around 60 000 parents will be
brought into work working an average of
16 hours per week and a similar impact
on total hours worked will come from
parents who are already working
increasing the amount that they're
working in paid employment
as this chart shows though that's
relatively a relatively small share of
the total amount that we're going to be
spending on this policy only around a
sixth of the places that will be
supported by this policy will be new
child care that parents are taking up
because they're moving into work the
Lion's Share of this is really a
transfer from the government to families
with young children
that said the chancellor spoke quite a
bit yesterday about the labor Supply
impact that he expects this policy to
have and indeed hopes that this policy
will have that sits a little bit oddly
alongside the design of the system
itself first of all the 30-hour offer
covers 30 hours a week only for 38 weeks
of the Year reflecting its Origins as a
term Time Early Education policy
families can spread those hours over
more weeks but that comes at the cost of
fewer weekly hours more like 22 hours a
week if you're spreading it over every
week of the year
second the entitlement will only cover
families where all parents are working
there's no support if the rules are the
same as the current 30-hour offer for
people who are in education people who
are training people who are looking for
work and these are the kinds of groups
that we might think that we would
particularly want to incentivize to
build up those skills if what we're
looking for is an increase in
productivity in our labor market not
just an increase in the total number of
people there
and quite importantly
using the 30-hour entitlement sets up
some odd design issues for the timing of
when families get support at the moment
under the 30-hour offer you become
eligible the term after your child turns
three assuming that you are working and
you have to apply in advance to get an
eligibility code to certify that the
government recommends that you apply
between four and ten weeks before the
term starts and you actually start
accessing that place so you have a
period where you need to be in work
presumably paying for child care out of
pocket in order to apply for and then
use your 30-hour offer that creates
quite an upfront barrier for some
families trying to move into work which
sits particularly oddly within this
budget given that the chancellor was at
pains to remove some of those upfront
barriers through the Universal Credit
system for low-income families wanting
to move into work
the final Oddity here although it
affects a relatively small number of
people it affects them to quite a
considerable extent the 30-hour offer is
withdrawn entirely
instantaneously when one parent in a
household earns more than a hundred
thousand pounds per year tax-free Child
Care is also withdrawn at that point and
so that creates a really big hit to work
incentives for parents at that high
point in the income distribution
here I'm showing you in green uh parents
post-tax earnings based on their what
they would have been earning gross on
the on the x-axis along the bottom and
then in yellow what that looks like once
we net off their child care expenses now
between up until we get to a hundred
thousand pounds per year the difference
between that green line and that yellow
line is relatively small and that
reflects the generosity of the giveaway
that Chancellor announced yesterday most
of these these parents will now be
getting most of their child care
expenses funded through this new
entitlement
but once we hit a hundred thousand
pounds the story changes that
entitlement goes away tax-free Child
Care goes away and all of a sudden those
child care costs make a much bigger deal
to families take-home pay and indeed we
estimate that a parent with two two very
young children under the age of three
using 40 hours of child care a week
would actually be better off earning 99
000 pounds than they would be earning
000 pounds so there's a huge region here
where parents would either refuse a pay
rise or more likely make changes to
their pension contributions to try and
muddle with the system and retain those
quite valuable entitlements
even more broadly though the focus on
labor Supply shifts the way that our
early year system works in this chart
I'm showing you the total amount of
spending on the early years through free
entitlement programs through the benefit
system and through programs like
tax-free child care and apportioning it
to different groups the light green at
the bottom is programs that are
Universal based just on the age of the
child the dark gray is programs that are
targeted at working families who are not
eligible for Universal Credit
um the light blue is low-income workers
so specifically those who are on
Universal Credit and the pink at the top
is low-income families kind of
independent of their working status
clear this reform the amount that we
spend for Universal programs will fall
from just under a half to about 30
percent of the total and the amount that
we spend on programs targeted at Working
Families will almost double reaching
nearly 60 percent of total spending on
the early years so we see from this the
real shift in the shape of our early
years spending and who it is that we're
trying to reach with those subsidies
has implications for more traditional
distributional analysis as well this is
a kind of classic ifs post-budget decile
chart where we've grouped families into
10 bins based on their household
earnings poorest at the left richest at
the right what stands out here is that
the poorest families don't benefit much
from this policy at all mainly because
they're not working and so they're not
eligible but also because even if they
do work they tend to have much lower
child care expenses we then see that the
benefits increase steadily over the
income distribution reflecting the fact
that higher income families tend to be
those where parents are working more
hours and therefore paying for more
child care expenses so this giveaway is
worth more to those towards the top of
the income distribution the fall we get
in the top decile at the very richest
reflects some of those uh consequences
of that withdrawal at a hundred thousand
pounds that I spoke about just before
yeah
this all sounds like potentially very
good news for parents quite a big
giveaway particularly to those who are
working a lot and using a lot of child
care but the core uncertainty and risk
here is around funding rates even before
any sort of Behavioral change so just
based on the child care patterns that we
see today the government will now be
setting the price for 80 percent of
preschool child care hours delivered in
England that's up from 50 percent
you control that much of the market
risks to getting that funding rate wrong
become much much bigger you might see
that providers don't offer the free
entitlement or they cut back on the
quality of the care they deliver or even
if the funding rate is not sufficiently
enticing that they leave the child care
Market altogether
but somewhat reassuringly I'm sure for
some providers the government does at
least seem to have budgeted enough to
significantly raise the rates for
two-year-olds and to introduce a higher
rate for the under twos we heard yet
yesterday from the chancellor that he's
intending a 30 uplift in the
two-year-old rate which will raise that
to about seven pounds 80 per hour and
then if we assume that the government's
plan is to freeze that in real is to
protect that in real terms over the
forecast Horizon to be clear this is an
assumption just to give us a ballpark
sense of these funding rates and that
seven pound 80 rate would be worth
around eight pounds 25 in cash terms by
2027. if we take that number and we use
the obr's estimates for the labor Supply
impact of this policy
we estimate that the funding announced
yesterday could allow for a rate for the
under twos of just under 11 pounds in
cash terms by 2027 so considerably
higher than the current two-year-old
rate which itself will be considerably
higher than the two-year-old rate that's
currently on offer
the big question here is just how
uncertain the right rate is it's really
hard to get these things right it's hard
to get the data it's hard to reflect all
of the different dimensions on which
providers vary and so the government
will need to be responsive to evidence
if that those rates aren't working in
the way that they intend we need to
understand a little bit more about the
mechanisms for setting these rates
reviewing them and revising them not
what we've tended to see in the past
with the free entitlement where the rate
gets frozen in cash terms for a little
while things start to look a little bit
sticky the government announces a big
one-off increase and then we see another
cash terms freeze that erodes the rate
in real terms
yeah Chancellor also announced some
policy reforms yesterday for low-income
workers through the Universal Credit
system now these have become less
important because of the big expansion
in the free entitlement that's going to
reduce demand through the Universal
Credit system amongst those youngest
children who make up around half of
current Universal Credit Child Care
spending but even so changing the timing
of universal child credit Child Care
subsidies is likely to help some parents
move into work at the moment they have
to pay their first month of child care
expenses out of pocket before waiting to
be reimbursed for 85 percent of those
costs by the government that leaves
families who are moving into work for
the first time on average about a third
worse off in their first month of work
because they're paying for child care
out of pocket and their paycheck hasn't
yet hit their account
but while changing the timing of these
Child Care subsidies will almost
certainly be welcomed by families the
risks here are around overpayments and
fraud if people claim for child care
expenses that they're not actually
entitled to it will be difficult for the
government to see a way of getting all
of that money back
the final piece here was the chancellor
raised the caps on child care expenses
in Universal Credit by 50 that nearly
restores their real terms value after an
18-year freeze since they were first
introduced as part of the Legacy benefit
system
but while this is a good policy making
to finally end the cash terms freeze in
the tax and benefit system and that
should almost always be celebrated in
actual fact this reform will have a
relatively limited impact on families
because for most of them the cats that
we had even beforehand weren't
particularly binding the average payout
was worth only around half of the cap
that families get just for one child
in summary Child Care reforms announced
yesterday deliver effectively a new
branch of the welfare state and the
scale of them make the consequences of
funding that branch of the welfare state
incorrectly much more severe than they
currently are
but the bigger picture here is what we
want our earlier system to achieve and
where we're putting our priorities and
our money at the moment with these
reforms the chancellor has really
shifted and made it very clear that he
wants to prioritize particularly
supporting families with child care
costs which will be most of what this
current spending on the new free
entitlement program will support helping
families who are already paying for
those hours hopefully bringing some more
into work but we've heard much less
about the impacts on Child Development
which will be potentially an issue for
the sector as a whole thinking about
moving from An Early Education offer to
something very much focused on labor
Supply
thank you
well thank you all
um that was uh as as those listening
will tell we've uh we we've delved deep
and we've uh had much to analyze and
much to say and probably said rather too
much given that that's taken a bit more
of the time than planned we will we've
got lots and lots of questions to get
through and uh we will carry on a bit
past 12 for those of you who want to
um who want to see uh answers to some
more of those
um questions and to some extent to speed
things up I'll take
um uh some of the questions uh quickly
um uh myself
um let's take something but um there's a
question about the high income child
benefit charge which has been uh for has
been um
voted right to the top what difference
would removing the high income child
benefit charge make the middle income
families why was it set up with
threshold standardized inflation it's
crazy at 250k pay nothing back 160k pay
all back well I don't think we could
agree more uh with um that
statement
um Rob you're on the call do you want to
um add anything to that or indeed Tom
but yeah I mean just uh yeah it's a
great it is pretty crazy it means that
if you've got two or three kids the
effect of tax rate you face in that 56
000 pound range it can get very very
high and it's very difficult to think of
a good reason to do that and because
those thresholds are frozen uh it also
means the effective tax rate you face
gets higher every year because the the
value of the child benefit being
withdrawal goes up so um it is a clear
area where which is right for reform I
think it's fair to say yeah
sorry I would just very quickly at it
it's worth putting that together with
the picture that Christine showed about
the the child care Cliff veg at a
hundred thousand pounds a year so even
higher but you put this together we are
making an absolute Pig's breakfast of
the of the of the packs and transfer
system for for higher earning families
and which is which is having a bigger
and bigger impact all the time because
the 100 000 pound threshold is also
Frozen every year yeah I mean this is
beginning to get um really quite
complicated and really quite damaging
this set of um things that people are
getting that lots of people will
probably put lots of effort into getting
round some of these absurd uh uh
idiocies in the tax system which affects
people from 50 000 pounds upwards
um Tom Reeves of Bloomberg
um asked deals to end the public sector
strikes are looking more likely and
indeed it looks like we may even have
had a settlement or be very close to a
settlement for the nurses given the tiny
Headroom will public sector play Awards
mean hunt will effectively break his
fiscal rules and how costly will those
deals B and Ben do you want to come in
on that one
yes I can do I think it's important to
distinguish here between the any
temporary one-off
bonus for public sector workers which is
reportedly going to be part of this NHS
offer which you could fund through
either higher borrowing or through
raiding the treasury's reserve its
buffer
and any permanent Consolidated pay
Awards if you have bigger Consolidated
pay Awards than what was budgeted for
you either have to ask departments to
somehow find that from within their
existing budgets that's very difficult
without big cuts to headcount or you
provide some extra cash I think we don't
know yet which of those it's going to be
but if the chancellor does feel like he
has to provide some extra cash to public
services that could potentially tip him
over into missing those fiscal rules or
being much closer to missing them than
he is already
thank you um Richard Partington of the
Guardian has asked could scrapping of
the lifetime allowed to help more
Bankers than NHS doctors and why do you
believe it probably won't play a big
part in increasing employment
um I I don't know how how many bangers
it will affect relative to doctors I do
think that if the fundamental problem
that it was trying to address was
doctors uh then it was a rather large
Sledgehammer to crack a very small nut
and a billion pound uh Sledgehammer uh
at that as Isaac said
um uh it's really actually genuinely
unclear Which Way its impact on the
employment will go uh in the long run
given that it will allow people to save
more in a pension and therefore
potentially at least retire earlier with
a bigger pension pot and we don't have
any quantitative estimates of our own
I'm afraid
um Richard Vaughn from the eye newspaper
this one for you Christine you're able
to say whether the amount provided in
the budget will be enough to ensure a
sustainable child care
system
I'd love to be able to say that I think
fundamentally no one can say that at
Santee the problem here is it's really
difficult to get a sense of what
providers costs ought to be
um particularly if the government is
also interested in keeping things
running efficiently so the real question
is going to be what the mechanisms are
for revising those rates if we come in
at one level and it looks like they are
too low and it looks like it's not
working the real danger is that we
double down on that and stick with
underfunding we need a better system to
keep things moving with the evidence
that we get
hey
um
uh next one from Ed Conway uh from Sky
I'm gonna throw this at you Carl can you
explain which measures are and are not
scored by the obr for growth uh he says
he vaguely recalls their own score
supply side reforms
um though I think in here there are some
in a sense the increase in the numbers
of people in work that they've scored
are coming from supply side reforms Carl
have you got anything to add to that uh
oh not so much I mean often when there's
a reform which um had a big effect what
the obr will do is perhaps not take
account of that big effect in the actual
scorecard but it might adjust its
forecast for earnings grow for household
spending
um so it might adjust its macro forecast
and allow it to work through that way
often with when reforms happen the obr
and the past has taken the view of well
relative to the difficulty of
forecasting productivity growth we don't
really think there's enough evidence yet
this would move the dial and would be
being overly precise to say that we now
think productivity growth is going to be
Epsilon higher than what it we
previously fought and therefore we're
just going to wait and see how emerging
evidence comes through and don't forget
the obr like many people over the last
decade or so has often overestimated
rather than underestimated productivity
growth
um I think with the measures yesterday
it seemed pretty clear they were taking
into account some labor Supply effects
from the pensions change from the child
care change
um there's good reasons to think in
particular the child care one will have
some impact on labor Supply so it's good
they're taking that into account I get
the impression that perhaps in previous
years they would have taken a more kind
of well we'll wait and see we'll see how
the reforms get implemented and how they
work through before adjusting and
perhaps of being a bit more proactive
now
um that may well be an improvement but
it might explain why we're seeing a bit
more of a shift now and perhaps less of
a shift when reforms were done in
earlier years of the obr's um existence
brilliant and there's a question of how
housing which seems quite popular we
didn't see anything with the chancellor
on housing
um despite working housing crisis how
the conservatives given up on trying to
be the party of home ownership well I
don't know what the conservatives are
doing what their view is uh but
um I think it's fair to say that housing
policy uh remains a dog's a dog's
breakfast
um we've spoken a lot about the problems
with council tax which um uh is uh Falls
too heavily on those with low value
houses and not heavily enough on those
with high value houses we've said a lot
about the huge problems with stamp Duty
which cause enormous trouble in the
housing uh Market we know that there are
problems here with with planning policy
um we know of course that home ownership
has pretty much halved among
um people in their late 20s and early
30s over the last 25 years with a
particular impact on middle income uh
people in that um in that age group
related of course to high big rises in
house prices uh actually one might hope
uh that a more sensible level of
interest rates over the coming years
whilst uh difficult for people in the
short run might bring uh house prices a
little bit down and actually help to
some extent those um who are looking to
move on to the housing ladder Robert
cuff has asked is the chancellor cooking
the books to meet his fiscal rules and
how does it approach me how that is his
predecessor
um I'll come to Carl in a moment cooking
the books might be putting it a little
strongly but certainly
by as all of its predecessors have done
pretending uh that he's going to get
money from fuel duties into the future
uh by
um uh claiming post-election uh that uh
spending is going to go up extremely
um slowly in this particular occasion
um by saying he wants the full expensing
to continue permanently but he's only
going to put it in the books for the
next three years he's causing he's he's
flattering his fiscal books and causing
absurd amount of uncertainty uh for
companies looking to
um uh to invest and there are a number
of other things in there where we have
um we have targets to increase spending
on defense to two and a half percent of
national income uh for example on
overseas AIDS still to get it to 0.7 of
national income on circumstances allow
um there's a lot of stuff in there uh
which uh makes I think the numbers less
convincing uh them or less transparent
than they might have been Carl do you
want to add anything to that yeah I mean
just a bit I mean I mean there's good
reasons to want a forward-looking fiscal
Target so if if you're doing the right
thing it allows you time to adjust if
Shocks come along
um you can support households and
businesses if you've got temporarily bad
news
um so there's good reasons to want a
forward-looking Target I think the
problem what it generates is that a a
Chancellor that was looking to exploit
that inappropriately could start to do
things like oh I'll just promise some
tax Rises or some spending cuts that
I'll never deliver
um and it's particularly obvious when
you've got a debt Target that says
debt's got a full between year four and
five that's basically no constraint on
your behavior in years two and three if
anything racking up more debt earlier
will make it easier to make it full
subsequently so there's a particular
weakness of the current Target that
makes it gamable and it's particularly
worrying when you then start to see
policy measures like expensing where the
chancellor said he wants it to be
permanent
um but he said it's only going to be in
place of three years is it a coincidence
it's in for the three years and actually
makes his physical Target easier to meet
not harder to meet
um and it feels that you know there may
be some gaming going on in terms of his
predecessors during the early 2010s when
the outlook for the economy was
constantly getting revised downwards Mr
Osborne as Chancellor kept pushing back
the date at which we get to current
budget surplus he was doing that through
extending the squeeze on public services
You could argue that was not an
unreasonable response to take more time
to get back to balance if you're going
to cut spending let's do it gradually
over time of course what we then saw is
that as soon as we got the other side of
a general election he immediately topped
those spending plans up so it's also
questionable whether those spending
plans were ever really what he intended
to deliver
there's a whole lot of questions here
about the pensions changes and their
impact on people in the um in the NHS I
mean I think I'll I'll come to Carl and
boss and Isaac in a moment I think our
general view is that there's there's
actually a fairly strong case for
increasing the annual allowance for what
you can put into pensions and probably
some increase in the
um lifetime allowance
um though uh that that is for reasons
other than helping people uh in the NHS
that's simply to make a slightly more
coherent system but it only really makes
sense to do that if you're also going to
limit some of the other extraordinary uh
benefits for example and there's a
question about this at the bottom
um you uh if you um if you if your
pension pot is inherited before you hit
75 then it's inherited free of income
tax and inheritance tax you also
obviously got up to a quarter of a
million pounds
um of tax-free lump sum which happily is
being limited to that amount as these as
these changes are made you've got
extraordinary complexity only for very
high earners to be sure but
extraordinary complexity associated with
the
um with the withdrawal of uh these
release incredible generosity around uh
National Insurance contributions and so
on so this really ought to have come as
part of a more uh a more complete
package of uh reform
um but but Carla Isaac do you want to
add anything to that and with particular
reference to the um issues in the NHS
yeah well I mean I suppose I'll just say
in terms of how well targeted it is I
mean it's it's targeted at people who um
would like to or are likely to
save more than a million pounds in their
pension or would like to or are likely
to save more than forty thousand pounds
in their pension in a given year uh doc
you know senior doctors probably are one
of the groups that potentially fall into
that category they're certainly not the
only group there are lots of other
groups who may well um benefit uh I
think exactly as you said before Paul if
what you were specifically trying to do
with this policy is just Target NHS
workers this would be far too broad a
way to do it but there are um there are
things to life in this box you know uh a
priority no reason to say that people
shouldn't say war on the pension if they
want to the problem as you say is that
there are these tax breaks that come
along with that additional saving which
are going to be handed out to people who
potentially have really very big pension
pods
but I I mean I mean the other thing I
would say and I said um in my opening
remarks about the pension policy is just
again all over the place it's this
government that dramatically reduced
these allowances and it's now increasing
them uh again and um a lot of the
problem uh related to the original
changes which um frankly were not
terribly well
um thought through
um another one for Christine
um do we have anything to say about what
the childcare subsidies will do for the
price of ours in holidays or for more
than 30 hours a week and is there a
danger that that will uh we pushed that
those prices would be pushed up
yeah so that's that's exactly the risk
here at the moment the government is
funding about 50 of the hours the child
care hours in England under these
reforms that goes up to 80 or even a
little bit more as people
um start taking up that new entitlement
if you're in a situation as a nursery or
a child monitor where the funding rate
you get for those government funded
hours isn't high enough then you're
looking at either raising sort of
voluntary contributions or nappy fees
for the children who are taking their
free entitlements if the government says
no you can't do that then you're looking
at putting up prices on that 20 of the
market where you still have the
flexibility to do that that's a really
small share of the market to be trying
to recoup losses from the vast majority
of the child care market so that's the
risk that things could unravel but I
think in practice what we're it comes
back to the funding rates the government
is planning to increase those rates and
to offer a higher rate for particularly
for the under twos
um and we also think that a lot of the
provision that this policy is going to
subsidize is child care that's already
happening in the market so I note that
the question also references are we
going to need loads of new child minders
are we going to need loads new nurseries
we estimate we'll need about 65 000 new
30-hour places from people moving into
work and demanding more care that's not
nothing but it's worth pet putting that
against the change that we saw in ratios
for the two-year-olds which should free
up about 50 000 30 hour places if those
kind of ratios are fully binding and
fully passed through and providers
Implement them so it's it will be
difficult there will be pressures on the
sector but it's not perhaps quite as
dramatic as it's all just completely
completely unworkable
right thank you
um
I'm going to run down and take some
slightly rather just taking the ones
right at the top here
um there's uh I'm going to bring David
in um here
um did we learn anything at all about
the outlook for local government
um in the budget and um uh we got
anything to say about
um issues around adult social care via
local Authority financial trouble and so
on David have you got anything to add on
local government yes so there wasn't
much specifically on local government uh
in the budget there was a Top-Up to the
potholes uh fund so whilst there's a lot
of talk about Devolution and there was
actually some action on Devolution with
greater Manchester and Birmingham and so
on and if those things are rolled out
nationally the sort of single pots are
funding they will get it would be quite
a change but when it comes to money on
potholes the government tells councils
you know what to spend on this so it's
quite a sort of contrast to the sort of
you know the Devolution approaches of
ring fencing of coach otherwise not very
much on local government but I think
this kind of uh implications from the
some of the other changes for councils
um so councils may be involved in the uh
Child Care uh provision rollout some
councils do provide child care directly
um and also uh the chart which showed
what would happen to sort of all other
spending given increases in health
um Child Care defense and so on well
that could mean further pressure on
councils in the next spending of your
period they actually got quite a
generous settlement for the next two
years we think that real terms funding
can we have about six percent five
percent a year
um each year over the next two years but
24 25 26 onwards that looks much tougher
for councils and of course the
government postponed plan reforms to
social care into the next spending view
period when that funding is really tight
so whether they'll go ahead or not or
whether Council will have to find that
money themselves I think that's an open
question
okay I'm going to come to you again
David there's a question here about
um uh this is why stack investment zones
on top of freeports does that confirm
that freeports don't drive leveling up
have you got anything to say on that
yes so uh we had a report out on uh
freeports just before the budget
actually
um and it looks at you know the sort of
potential rationale for the policy what
the potential impacts might be and so on
so I think you can make a case for these
place-based policies
um the main case relates to
um the idea that there can be what I
call agglomeration benefits uh positive
externalities of having these economic
clusters where they can be used for
example knowledge exchange between firms
they can share infrastructure they can
share pools of skilled labor
um
and the tax incentives being provided
there's you know reasonably good
evidence they will attract activity to
these locations although a lot of
uncertainty about how much activity that
would be but of course there are risks
to this as well a lot of activity can be
displaced from elsewhere in the UK
um not just you know actually people
moving into the free ports or into the
investment zones it could be companies
um that you know otherwise would have
set up outside we now set up inside it
could be through the labor market it
could be
um the three Zone um investment Zone
um companies because of the tax
incentives can better compete for labor
and of course you do have Labor
shortages at the moment so what's the
potentially you create a case of these
they're also some significant risks with
these policies as well now I think the
kind of question there also is about why
is it being you know located
um in uh in these deprived areas as well
I think that's because it's been seen
which is a part of the leveling up
policy
um all of the investment zones or in the
north and Midlands in the areas where
there's a male combined Authority
um so I think it's been seen as part of
the sort of uh leveling up policy and as
part of
um plans to devolve and actually plans
to push more uh mirrors
um down the line because you know to get
these zones you need a mirror
fantastic and I'm going to throw the
next one
um at uh Carl
um and the question essentially is um if
we don't like the current set of fiscal
rules what will be a better set of
fiscal rules
right
um well there isn't a perfect fiscal
rule out there that um we'll we know we
should always obey in all periods and we
know that we'll reign in any chance to
and stop them from any misbehaving I
think we can certainly do a lot better
than saying we want debt to be falling
between year four and five and we're not
going to worry about death in any other
year I think it's quite clearly that's a
long way from being an appropriate
fiscal Target
um
I think stepping back from a little bit
I think I'd say well why do we want
fiscal targets we want them to
presumably help communicate what the
government's trying to do to get
credibility behind its plans to help
reassure voters help reassure markets
that there's a there's a sensible plan
for managing the country's finances and
with an independent obr with the ifs in
place other organizations are available
too
um you get a lot of scrutiny posts about
fiscal events we're able to show you
when for example the chancellor keeps
pretending that field Duties are going
to go up and they're never actually
doing it the obr has some analysis of
that too so we do have the the
information the transparency that allows
us to hold chances to account so you
know we're able to produce the numbers
that show you you know do you think
those spending plans are credible do you
think that
um or do you think actually no one
percent real is completely completely
fine or do you think no that's not going
to happen post-election we can kick the
tires on the forecast with all the
information we have so we shouldn't be
too gloomy that actually you know if a
Chancellor does misbehavior I think the
obr ourselves and others are pretty well
equipped to point out where
um where perhaps the the spirit behind
the rules is not being followed as
closely as it should be
brilliant thank you I've got to keep
going for another five minutes or so
given that um there are so many
questions uh but I'm afraid that means
uh we will overrun slightly
um uh but obviously those of you who
want to stay on uh please do
um question from Michael Phillips of the
nas uw-t PJ that's me said yesterday
it's not true that giving public sector
workers a bit more would certainly raise
inflation would a real terms pay
increase uh in boost recruitment number
retention and benefit the economy
um I think the I think the key Point
here is that
um keeping public sector pay falling
relative to that improv in the private
sector isn't sustainable um in the long
run without a fall in the quality of
Public Services because you'll either
not be able to recruit people at all or
you'll be able to recruit people who are
less well qualified than um in the past
so that is a key Choice
um for government we we saw quite a lot
of choices yesterday 20 billion a year
the chancellor found of extra tax cuts
and spending Rises elsewhere but not for
uh public sector workers though it seems
that there is something as we've heard
uh being cooked up today in terms of
settling the uh dispute with nurses
broadly speaking you can't simply
diverge public and private sector pay
over long periods of time but uh there
are always choices and it may be that
the government thinks that there are
better ways of supporting the economy
than increasing teachers and nurses pay
for example through uh incentives for
companies to invest there are always
choices
um in these um in these areas
um uh let's see what else we've got uh
here I mean there's lots of questions
about things that Chancellor didn't do
in terms of Net Zero
um and so on uh and lots more about
pensions but I don't think we'll go back
over uh
um pensions
um uh Steve shiffers has asked How
likely is it the chance of finding the
tax cuts in the next budget particularly
if the rolling forward of the date he
needs to meet is fiscal targets improves
his fiscal Headroom well I think in a
high level uh politically uh we wouldn't
be surprised to see some kind of tax
cuts announced in the next budget um
very often that is what happens just
before uh elections uh in the big
picture will be of course that even if
he does find room for that taxes at the
end of this Parliament and going forward
will be dramatically higher than they
were
um at the start
um of the parliament but Carl do you
want to say something again about
um where we might be because it's a
really important point where we might be
in terms of fiscal Headroom once we roll
forward
um uh an extra year at the next fiscal
event yeah I mean I think it's
I think it's pretty clear that when we
get to the Autumn the case for permanent
tax cuts that are not matched by
credible permanent spending cuts was
going to be pretty weak there is a
strong case for us aiming to get debt
down over the medium term and the reason
for that is we know that bad shocks come
along and that leads to debt increasing
given that we know that we can't always
have debt going up it seems sensible to
be aiming to get it down
um in the absence of those bad shocks so
nothing wrong with having tax cuts but
they need to be matched by credible
spending cuts and I think getting debt
down is going to be reproved to be quite
challenging for quite some time and
that's why I'm kind of pessimistic about
the case for that now of course
politically what you could see is a
situation where the chancellor is
forecasted extended for one more year if
he's going to pretend or claim that he
can get away with one percent real
spending growth for a couple of years
maybe he'll be tempted to put in one
percent for another year
um I presume he'll claim that he'll be
freezing he'll be increasing field
duties and line of inflation for that
one more here as well and I think we'd
be pretty confident that that isn't
going to happen whoever
um is chancellor at that point in time
um so I think what the risk is that we
put in a load of assumptions which make
the four cars flattered and we use that
flattering of the forecast to do some
tax cuts
um which don't then turn out to be
sustainable um so if we are going to cut
taxes if that's what we want to do we
want sustainable tax cuts that needs to
be matched by sustainable spending cuts
not Finance through measures that we're
not serious about implementing
fantastic
um
let's see uh
um what else I'm going to throw this one
uh at Ben I think um despite the extra
money for some areas they should be
offense does this budget leave
departments to manage the impact of
inflation wage and pension Rises when
their existing allocations meaning
significant squeezes pre-2025.
the answer is yes to an extent but not
by much more than was already the case
in the Autumn the uh official measure of
inflation for that's used for these
things the next couple of years is
largely unchanged relative to the Autumn
that's the GDP deflator the question is
whether that truly captures the cost
measure the costs facing departments in
terms of energy in terms of pay Awards
in terms of fuel and food and so on it
probably under States the true cost
pressures a bit particularly on things
like Capital budgets where construction
inflation is running at more like 10 or
15 so the answer is yes but not to a new
or surprising degree relative to what we
already knew about
fantastic thank you look we're already
five minutes over I think we should
probably
um uh bring things to an end uh there
um thank you ever so much uh to all my
colleagues speaking thank you to
everyone who has attended all of the our
analysis is of course up on our website
and the presentations that you have just
seen as well as a pretty comprehensive
uh Twitter uh feed
um from uh from the ifs and for myself
and from colleagues so do take a look at
all of that and we look forward to
seeing you at the next fiscal event
which I hope isn't until the Autumn
statement somewhere around uh November
thank you very much